[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos Hoy
empezamos hablando de los primeros días
de Gustavo Petro en Colombia una semana
movida Pues el mandatario presentó su
proyecto de reforma tributaria comenzó a
explorar Cómo reiniciar el proceso de
paz con la guerrilla de lln y dio pasos
para reanudar las relaciones
diplomáticas con la vecina Venezuela dos
naciones que comparten más de 2.000
kilómetros de frontera y cuyos
habitantes son los más afectados por las
decisiones de los jefes de estado que
hasta el momento se habían basado en la
diferencia de sus ideologías algo que
ahora más bien los acerca y vamos a Perú
porque el presidente Pedro Castillo
sigue contra las cuerdas la fiscalía
inició una nueva investigación en contra
del mandatario Con esta ya son seis las
pesquisas del ministerio público
inédito en la nación suramericana Y en
el otro frente del Congreso inició un
proceso en su contra por la traición a
la patria por el que podría ser obligado
a abandonar la casa de Pizarro su
abogado renunció y luego volvió a
aceptar defenderlo y visitamos el norte
del continente Mary Garland del fiscal
general de Estados Unidos defendió la
legalidad del allanamiento a la mansión
del ex presidente Donald Trump en
Florida como parte de un proceso para
determinar si se llevó documentos
clasificados de la Casa Blanca el hecho
ocurrió en la misma semana en la que fue
citado a declarar por la fiscal general
de Nueva York por otro caso que
investiga sus negocios en la gran
manzana por lo que Trump y sus
seguidores aseguraron que se trataba de
una cacería de brujas
y vamos de inmediato a Colombia para
nuestra historia principal en menos de
una semana en el cargo el presidente
Gustavo Petro hizo varios anuncios
relevantes desde presentar al congreso
su proyecto de reforma tributaria un
tema controversial en el país y que en
2021 desató el estallido social en
contra del entonces presidente Iván
Duque que presentó un proyecto que
castigaba principalmente a la clase
media hasta el viaje de una delegación a
Cuba con la intención de reanudar los
diálogos con la guerrilla de lln pasando
por el nombramiento del embajador en
Venezuela con miras a restablecer las
relaciones entre los dos países rotas
desde 2019 les resumimos Los tormentosos
lazos de estos dos países hermanos en el
siguiente informe que preparamos para
ustedes
Nicolás Maduro llegó al poder en
Venezuela en abril de 2013 tras la
muerte de Hugo Chávez
[Música]
entonces en Colombia el presidente era
Juan Manuel Santos
ya había iniciado una nueva era en las
relaciones entre Bogotá y Caracas que
tuvieron una serie de altibajos durante
el mandato de Álvaro Uribe Vélez hasta
romperse en 2010 cuando el conservador
colombiano acusó al régimen venezolano
de permitir que las guerrillas de las
FARC y del Ln se refugiaran en su
territorio
responsabilizamos A la oligarquía
colombiana y a su actual gobierno
heredero de Santander si estas naciones
hermanas tiñen de sangre su historia
cuento El pueblo venezolano y el
gobierno colombiano
con una respuesta contundente por parte
de la Fuerza Armada nacional bolivariana
en su rol de garante de la defensa
integral de la nación si fuerzas
extranjeras
intentasen de alguna manera violar el
Sagrado suelo
no obstante una nueva crisis se zanjó en
2015 cuando maduro ordenó el cierre del
puente internacional Simón Bolívar que
une el venezolano estado táchira con el
colombiano norte de Santander y deportó
a los colombianos que se encontraban
allí supuestamente por estar Implicados
En un ataque a unos soldados venezolanos
en la zona fronteriza así como en
actividades ilícitas como el contrabando
de gasolina
no fue hasta 2016 que la frontera fue
reabierta luego de que miles de personas
cruzaran a Colombia por caminos
improvisados buscando comida medicinas y
otros productos de primera necesidad que
escaseaban en el país petrolero
denuncio ante el mundo que Juan Manuel
Santos está preparando
planes macabros para dejar una situación
comprometida de enfrentamiento bélico
entre Venezuela y Colombia en la
frontera así como hizo Álvaro Uribe
en enero de 2019 Estados Unidos bajo el
mando entonces de Donald Trump reconoció
al presidente de la asamblea venezolana
Juan guaidó como el presidente legítimo
del país y desconoció los resultados de
las elecciones presidenciales de 2018 en
los que maduro obtuvo la victoria pero
que no contaron con un proceso
transparente de convocatoria y
registraron con la abstención más alta
en la historia de los comicios
presidenciales desde la llegada de la
democracia en 1958
Colombia
también ha reconocido a Juan guaidó como
presidente de Venezuela también Brasil
Chile Ecuador y muchos otros países de
América Latina y espero que en las
próximas horas tengamos a grupo de Lima
dando una declaración Creo que este es
un paso necesario para recuperar la
democracia en Venezuela
Colombia dirigida ahora por Iván Duque
siguió los pasos de Trump y legítimo a
Juan guaidó Washington ofreció ayuda
humanitaria a Venezuela que entraría por
la frontera colombiana y maduro aseguró
que se trataba de una excusa para una
invasión militar y cerró las fronteras
en febrero de 2019 se celebró en el lado
colombiano de la frontera un concierto
con el objetivo de presionar a maduro a
que permita ingresar la ayuda
humanitaria en respuesta maduro rompe
relaciones diplomáticas con Colombia y
les da 24 horas a los funcionarios
diplomáticos de aquel país para
retirarse
en 2021 Duque anunció la apertura de la
frontera entre Venezuela y Colombia
fueron removidos los contenedores que
bloqueaban el paso de vehículos y quiero
una vez más reiterarle mi gratitud a esa
resistencia democrática ese gobierno
interino por Buscar también la presión
para permitir esa reapertura que
beneficia a nuestros pueblos
sin embargo hasta la llegada de Gustavo
Petro al poder no había conversaciones
diplomáticas entre Caracas y Bogotá
los más afectados del devenir de las
relaciones entre ambos países son los
habitantes de los
2.341 kilómetros de frontera que muchas
veces tienen doble nacionalidad y ven
afectada su vida diaria por las
decisiones de los jefes de estado que
hasta el momento se habían basado en la
diferencia de sus ideologías
[Música]
y ahora vamos a Perú porque la fiscalía
inició una nueva investigación en contra
del presidente Pedro Castillo Con esta
ya son seis las pesquisas del ministerio
público en contra del mandatario
convirtiéndolo en el primero en
ejercicio en la historia del país en ser
investigado por la fiscalía a este nuevo
caso de presunto delito contra la
tranquilidad pública en la modalidad de
organización criminal se suman las
acusaciones de presunto tráfico de
influencias en los ascensos de
integrantes de las fuerzas armadas
también por crímenes de organización
criminal presunto tráfico de influencias
y colusión por la adjudicación de
contratos en el caso puente tarata
también plagio y falsedad por el
presunto plagio de su tesis doctoral
delitos contra la administración pública
en la compra de biodiésel este es el
caso Petro Perú y el presunto delito de
encubrimiento por los múltiples cambios
en el Ministerio del interior el
mandatario defiende su inocencia y
asegura que se trata de un complot en su
contra escuchemos
queridos compatriotas
quieren a través de esa agenda mediática
de ese show mediático coludidos
con sectores que nunca han hecho nada
por el Perú quieren doblegarnos estas
investigaciones no pueden llevar a
Castillo a abandonar el cargo porque
como presidente tiene inmunidad ante
esto El Congreso de Perú inició un
proceso en su contra por el único cargo
por el que sí puede verse obligado a
abandonar la casa de Pizarro Y ustedes
traiciona la patria el caso se remonta a
una entrevista que dio a Fernando del
Rincón de la cadena CNN en español en la
que Castillo decía que estaría dispuesto
a ceder parte de su territorio del
territorio del Perú a Bolivia para que
Bolivia obtenga una salida al mar el
abogado del Castillo Benji Espinosa
abandonó el barco Y renunció a
defenderlo esta semana pero tras
reunirse con él se retrató
y vámonos para Nueva York para revisar
la imagen de la semana el ex presidente
de Estados Unidos Donald Trump sale de
la Torre Trump para una cita con la
fiscal general del estado de Nueva York
dos días después de que agentes del FBI
allanarán su mansión de mar al lago en
Florida una semana difícil para el
republicano Trump acogió a la quinta
enmienda de la Constitución y evitó así
responder las preguntas de la fiscal en
una investigación de sus prácticas
comerciales y el negocio inmobiliario de
su familia en Nueva York durante 4 horas
el ex mandatario invocó la quinta
enmienda que establece el Derecho a no
responder para no incriminarse para
evadir todas y cada una de las preguntas
como las dos cosas sucedieron en la
misma semana el presidente
estadounidense afirmó que se trataba de
una cacería de brujas mensaje que al
parecer hizo ella pues el mismísimo
fiscal general de Estados Unidos Mary
Garland tuvo que salir a justificar la
legalidad del procedimiento
en una rara e inusual conferencia de
prensa El fiscal general de Estados
Unidos Mary Garland defendió la
legalidad del allanamiento a la
residencia de mar al lago de Donald
Trump
la orden de allanamiento fue autorizada
por el tribunal Federal tras la
determinación requerida de causa
probable el recibo de propiedades un
documento que la ley federal exige que
los agentes del orden público dejen al
dueño de la propiedad el departamento
presentó la moción para hacer pública la
orden y el recibo a la luz de la
confirmación pública del registro por
parte del ex presidente las
circunstancias circundantes y el interés
público sustancial en este asunto
una respuesta tácita a las críticas del
ex mandatario de sus seguidores que
acusaron al buró Federal de
investigación de tener motivaciones
políticas para la requisa Los Seguidores
del ex mandatario aseguran que el
servicio de inteligencia abusó de su
poder durante el procedimiento
Generalmente el departamento de Justicia
guarda silencio durante las
investigaciones en curso pero el fiscal
general argumentó que se trata de un
caso de interés general las pesquisas se
centran en determinar si Trump retiró
documentos de la Casa Blanca después de
abandonarla especialmente sobre su papel
en el asalto al Capitolio por parte de
sus seguidores Pero adicionalmente según
el Washington post el FBI estaba
buscando documentos clasificados sobre
armas nucleares el ex mandatario asegura
que se trata de una cacería de brujas
fue el propio ex presidente Trump el que
dio los detalles de que se había hecho
este este llamamiento en su propiedad y
entonces empezó a lanzar acusaciones
diciendo entre otras cosas que era
posible que hasta que lo hubieran
plantado evidencia los agentes del FBI y
del departamento de Justicia las mismas
agentes de la seguridad del servicio
secreto que estaban protegiendo de la
vida a Trump y a su señora y a su
familia fueron Víctimas de estas
insinuaciones entre tanto esta misma
semana un juez de Nueva York vio que el
juicio por presunto fraude fiscal contra
la organización Trump comenzará en
octubre
y miles de brasileños Se tomaron las
calles de Sao Paulo para manifestarse a
favor de la democracia y los sistemas
electorales del país que el presidente
Yahir bolsonaro ha atacado los
manifestantes también acudieron a la
facultad de derecho de la Universidad de
Sao Paulo para recrear un evento que se
llevó a cabo allí hace 45 años en 1977
una multitud de personas se reunió en
este mismo lugar para escuchar la
lectura de la llamada carta a los
brasileños un manifiesto que pedía el
pronto retorno del Estado de derecho en
medio de la dictadura militar
[Música]
gracias por acompañarme en aquí América
en la producción estuvieron Giovanni
agudelo y Andrés doncel pueden ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web France 24.com por favor
envíenme sus comentarios en redes
sociales a la dirección que ven en su
pantalla y Para más información de
nuestro continente Sigan viendo France
[Música]